in the past we've graphed a lot of
things before right I want to remind you
of a couple of the things that you've
graphed recently if I asked you to graph
something like this here we go
we've got equations like this sometimes
we work equations like this out of these
variation all these proportion problems
do you remember that so this is some
quantity that's equal to double sum of a
quantity okay number of people in the
room sorry no other way around number of
people in the room number of eyes in the
room that makes sense doesn't it 30
people in the room multiplied by 2 60
eyes in the room okay so this is a
variation relationship we also saw
things like this this is also variation
but it's another kind you remember what
kind of watch had a special notice added
with an eye inverse right inverse
variation so this is not when two
numbers get bigger together it's one
number gets bigger and the other gets
smaller okay now you've got um you've
got desmos here to help you work out
what these look like and you've we've
seen pictures of these before so go
ahead put your cursor up in the top left
hand corner and go ahead and type in the
first one let me turn off my internet
because I know what will happen if I
don't you were all too slow today now
yeah okay there's um scuse me
there's y equals 2x just a straight line
so we've seen this before and if at the
same time I also draw you can just press
enter y equals two divided by X you get
this just kind of interesting okay so
think about what these red and blue
lines mean the red line is direct
variation one quantity goes up the other
quantity also goes up right whereas the
blue line is an inverse variation or
inverse proportion as you can see when I
go up on this the blue gets closer to
this side so this number increases this
number
decreases okay or in the same way as
this number increases this number
decreases I get lower and lower and
lower as time goes on okay so for
instance this might be like the example
I gave before number of people in the
room and this is how much donut we get
to eat per person okay it gets smaller
and smaller as you share it out assuming
you guys are willing to share so these
are the pictures
these are what we're familiar with what
I want to contemplate or consider is
this guy I'm going to put one more to
but I'm going to put them in an unusual
spot I'm going to put it there now don't
say anything but I want you to raise
your hand if you know what kind of shape
we're going to get other hands up
straight I don't expect everyone to put
their heads I just want to see who would
put their hands up a small number okay
hands down fit them okay here's how
we're going to work this out right this
is going to require a tiny bit of leg
work here Shaya 10 but des knots is
going to do most of the legwork for us
okay
so the first thing I want to do is let's
switch off these graphs we don't need
them so what you do is you arm you click
on the colored bits on the left hand
side and your glass will disappear
they're still there but they just hit it
okay here's what we're going to do I
want to get some coordinates out of this
okay
so for instance if I said when x equals
something y equals something else and so
we're going to draw a little table of
values here can you draw this underneath
where you got this for me as well so I'm
going to try and look at next aisle you
compare it to a Y value let's start with
an easy one if x is 0 what's y equal to
Y a because Y is equal to zero squared
so this is just zero when X is equal to
one what's y equal to 1 because 1
squared is 1 but now we have a look
further the numbers start to get more
interesting when X is 2
x-squared before and 3 gives me okay
now des mots can help us graph this okay
what we're going to do is and I've done
this little little while so I might have
to remember some of this stuff do you
guys have that little plus icon in the
top left hand corner do you have that go
ahead and click on it do you have the
same options I have I've got expression
note table folder image D others yeah
okay can you click on table for me do
you have that you see what I've got okay
maybe your color is different doesn't
matter okay so you can see what created
an x and a y table just like we have an
X on Y table so what I want you to do is
pop the numbers we've got into here 0
and 0 then if you just press Enter I
think it'll go down to the next row and
you can add all of these in okay now as
you punch them in if you look at your
graph you will see something happening
that set of graph our set of values
rather now appears as coordinates do you
see it do you have them as well do you
have them appearing on your screen
ok thumbs up so what you've done just
like when we were looking at remembering
as the people who remember it were on
their computers and we're we're trying
to like plot the guy the parachute the
cannon man remember that we're not going
to it down and you would put some points
on them and you try and join them up
okay so I want you to have a look at
this graph you've got dots here what
kind of shape would join up all of these
dots can you sort of draw it with your
finger you sort of see it right okay so
now here's what we're going to do we
could have done to try at the beginning
but now we're going to create this shape
go ahead go to a new line and type in y
equals x and in fact you'll see probably
a squared button right there do you have
that if you have that go ahead and punch
it in
okay so the heading you can make is the
name of this shape which is parabolas
this is a parabola now can I get a show
of hands who's screen looks like this
hand up straight yeah okay hands down
what does yours look like if it doesn't
because a few people do have their hair
done
yeah actually quintanilla do it one
better key turn your screens around I
just want to see for your grass turn
around yep cool looking good looking
good okay
you haven't finished yet well what have
you done your interesting this is great
okay okay fantastic thank you you can
turn them back around to yourselves
Johnny can change me a favor before I
get there can you look at Al Jarreau and
work out what he's done I'll come to you
in a minute oh I think I know what
you've done
I think you've switched these around I
think you have these backwards ugly I
think you have your X's in your wives
and your wife in your ex's I think
that's what you've done that what you've
done I think that's what I think you
have these on this way okay now put your
pens down for a moment and in fact just
don't leave your laptop a job but just
shut it for a second I want us to look
at this shape and note a few things
about it we'll write these down together
okay for starters let's compare it to
these guys so this blue shape is called
a hyperbola and the same that's that's
different clearly these are different
but they share some things they share
some things in common
can someone anyone tell me something
that's common between the black and the
blue graph anything at all brown okay
number one they're both curved and
that's very very important okay someone
tell me something else
that's in common between them anyway
yeah go ahead watch say it again okay
they're both are infinite right there's
no point at which they stop that's also
very important right you see something
else they both go straighter when they
what how did you in that again what so
you're talking about like that way that
what you mean okay so this is so for
example and um I'll get you to do this
in a second but just watch it now if i
zoom in on this section here just have a
look at that right now now you know
where this graph comes from you know
what the rest of the picture looks like
but if you did it
doesn't that kind of look like a
straight line do you know that if you go
in far enough it looks like a straight
line and both of them do this you can do
the same thing with the blue line that
looks like a straight line too doesn't
it if you zoom in far enough where you
go to the right spot okay does anyone
else see anything that I haven't that
hasn't been mentioned Kate okay they're
books and this is a really key idea I
was wondering if you would get to this
one they're both symmetrical at least
one way so can you describe to me in
what way is on the blue graph how's that
symmetrical how would you describe it
symmetry maybe you've got hands can you
use some words what was it you that way
okay so if we put it in fact I will put
in y equals minus there we go
if you put in that red line and you just
just turn your head a little bit just
turn your head you can see the blue line
is symmetrical about that it's reflected
across do you agree okay now the y
equals x squared line isn't symmetrical
around this line it's symmetrical around
another line what line is it I'll give
you a tip for lines already on there
isn't it yeah very good it's the y axis
you can see you just sort of flip this
side over here now think about that for
a second why is that we only did
positive numbers we only did positive
numbers right but do you notice if you
had put in say negative 1 instead of 1
if X were negative 1 what would Y be
equal to it would still be 1 if X were
negative 2 what would Y be equal to it
would still be four why aren't there
negatives there
cuz it gets doubled it gets squared
right the the number of negative signs
doubles and they cancel each other out